[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening, and welcome
to tonight's performance
by Gamelan Galak Tika.
We hope that you enjoyed that
first selection, [INAUDIBLE]..
The next two pieces
will be performed
by a newly formed group as of
last year called Gamelan Anak
Tika or the Cambridge
Youth Gamelan.
As you see here, they
are made up of children.
Our group is in its
second year, and we
have students ranging from
third grade through ninth grade
although the group
that you see here
goes up to about sixth grade.
And this is a community
gamelan program
that meets once a week
throughout the entire year
to teach children how to play
traditional Balinese music
and dance on the instruments
that you see before you.
So the first piece that
we're going to perform
is a piece called "Gilak
Topeng [INAUDIBLE],","
which was taught to us by
our guest teacher from Bali
that visits the MIT group
every spring named Dewa Alit.
It's a teaching piece, so
what you're going to hear
is the kids playing
a shorter melody
and listening to the drum
for cues on how to get loud
and how to get quiet.
And the second piece is
a slightly longer piece
called "Baris" that is normally
performed with a male dancer
and is a very long
selection of music,
but we're playing about a
third of the music there
and without a dancer.
And in there, in that piece,
you're going to hear sort
of a flashy introduction
and responses to the drum
in what's called an
[NON-ENGLISH] where they stop
their cycle of music rather
kind of abruptly and switch
to a second pattern and then go
back to the original pattern.
So please welcome
onto the stage--
and they're already here--
the Cambridge Youth Gamelan.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "BARIS"]
[APPLAUSE]
So while we're just setting up
here for the next three pieces
before intermission,
I just wanted
to talk to you for a little bit.
So my name is Leslie.
I've had the pleasure of working
with this extraordinary group
of musicians for the last
three and a little bit months.
What you see when
Balinese gamelan happens,
everything that
happens on this stage
is learned by rote
with no written music,
with no instruments to
take home to practice on.
These people come together
in a group of 25 people
and play and learn together,
so that's kind of awesome.
You guys can sit.
How many people are at their
first gamelan show ever?
Oh whoa, a lot.
Awesome.
OK, so I just want to give
you a little guided tour
of the ensemble so
that you can have
a sense of what to listen for.
So when we play gamelan, a lot
of the music happens in cycles.
You'll hear melodies that sort
of circle around and around,
and what is holding
that together
at the heart of the gamelan is
these hanging gongs at the back
here.
They mark the cycle.
And this gong over
here-- will you wave?
Thank you very much.
It's called the kempli,
and it keeps the beat.
You might have noticed we
don't have a conductor,
so there's a kempli
keeping the beat.
There are other
people who are sort
of controlling when
things get softer
and louder and
slower and faster.
So what we're going
to do is basically
we're going to put
together one melody that
happens in the next piece that
we're going to play so that you
can hear sort of how all
the parts fit together,
and then you'll hear it in
the context of the piece.
So the very first thing
I just want to hear
is the gong structures.
It's an eight-beat
gong structure,
and you're going to hear that--
Ilya, will you just
hit the big gong?
[GONG HIT]
Yeah, that gong happens
at the end of every cycle.
So when you hear that
gong, it means the melody
is coming around again.
OK, go ahead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Awesome.
[GONG HIT]
Overexcited.
In the middle of
all of this is going
to be a melody that
moves every beat,
and that's played by this
musician over here on the ugal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All of these musicians on this
side of the ensemble-- oh,
wait.
This instrument here does
a lot of different things.
You're going to notice
it does different things
in different pieces.
In this particular
piece, secretly, it's
not usually used, but it's going
to be sort of mirroring what
the ugal does.
And these other
musicians back here
are going to be
playing sort of sparser
versions of that same
melody, so these guys here
are going to be playing
basically the same thing
that Sam is playing
over on the ugal.
These guys are going to be
playing every second note.
playing every fourth note,
so the more important notes get
emphasized by more instruments.
So can we maybe just start
with Sam and Matt, and then one
cycle, one cycle, one
cycle, or 2, 2, 2, 2?
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These guys are sparser.
Thank you.
Over on this side, these are
the fast, flowery melodies
that happen over top
of that, and they're
divided into partners.
Gamelan, especially
Balinese gamelan,
has this special
technique called kotekan,
which involves playing
a melody faster
than a single person can play
it alone on their instrument,
and so that melody
becomes shared
between you and your partner.
And so we're going to play
you the two parts separately,
and then we'll play you
how they fit together.
So just a tiny bit
slower than that.
[NON-ENGLISH].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And [NON-ENGLISH].
And here's how the two
of them sound together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cool, huh?
The last instruments
that I want to talk about
play a little bit more
of a rhythmic role.
So over here, you'll see this
tiny little plate of cymbals.
It's called ceng-ceng, and
that plays a sort of mostly
chucka-chucka-chucka-chucka
kind of rhythmic role to hold
everybody together.
But you'll notice, he also does
some other fun things, too.
And I'm going to
abandon you for a minute
because I play drums on this.
The drums play fun
rhythms, but then also,
the drummer is the person who's
directing the gamelan through--
Emeric, I think,
mentioned [NON-ENGLISH],,
when you get loud
and suddenly stop.
Those sorts of things are
directed through the drums.
When the tempo shifts,
when the dynamics shift,
this is all directed
through the drums as well.
So we'll just play you what
the drums and ceng-ceng
sound like alone, and
then after that, we'll
build it up from the slowest
instruments into the fastest
instruments so that you can
hear what this melody sounds
like all built up.
Cool?
Excellent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's how that works.
And so now we'll build it
up, two cycles of each,
starting from gongs and the next
sparsest instrument all the way
up. [? That's how ?]
[INAUDIBLE] coming together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So see if you can hear
that melody in this piece
that we're going
to play for you.
So we'll play this
piece, and then directly
after, we're going to play
the piece that was actually
composed by one of our
members, Sam, so [INAUDIBLE]..
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
We have one more
piece, and then there
will be a short intermission
while we move instruments.
And after the
intermission, we'll
be in an entirely different
gamelan with a piano soloist,
so please stick around for that.
And during the
intermission, there
will be some merchandise in
the lobby, CDs, t-shirts, PEZ
dispensers, things like that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
This particular project is
the culmination of something
that we started this
summer when we realized
that incredible influence and
person of the 20th century, Lou
Harrison, composer Lou Harrison,
that this was his centennial.
And we also realized
that we had one
of his great champions and
also, in fact, his teacher
of Javanese music, Jody
Diamond, in the area
along with the instruments
that he and his partner William
Colvig built.
So these instruments that
you're seeing on stage
were actually built by
hand by Lou and Bill
and named after their
patron, Betty Freeman,
and they are Gamelan Si Betty.
They are in the style
of a Javanese Gamelan,
although they have some touches
that are uniquely Lou and Bill.
The tuning was picked out
by Lou in collaboration
with his other Javanese
teacher, the master Pak Cokro,
and the designs are from
a Pennsylvania Dutch floor
pattern that Lou and
Bill painted themselves.
To do this piece-- this is a
piece he wrote in the 1980s
for his friend,
Belle Bullwinkle,
and his own gamelan,
which Jody was a part of.
And she has been
incredibly generous,
teaching us to play
traditional Javanese style
and then teaching us how to do
Lou Harrison's take on Javanese
style for this piece.
It's in three movements.
It both follows Javanese form,
which is similar to the forms
Leslie was showing
you in the first half,
but it has his own unique
sense of melody and drama.
We did this two
months ago at the ICA.
Were any of you there for that?
All right, well, so
I don't say anymore.
Thank you for coming again.
So we played with an
incredible pianist.
Sarah Cahill sends her regards.
She's in Japan right now,
playing Lou Harrison's music
there.
But the thing is that there's
such a depth of talent
in this ensemble that
while she was away,
I just kind of asked one of
the members, Nick Joliat,
if he could just kind of sub
for her on the piano part
during rehearsals.
So Sarah's amazing, and
she sounded incredible.
But he sounded so good that
we just thought, why don't we
just do it again with Nick?
He's in the neighborhood.
And so he is there at
the piano, and we're just
thrilled to play with him.
[APPLAUSE]
This is the end of the
residency of Si Betty at MIT
and Jody's residency with
us, and so we're a little bit
sentimental about that.
But hopefully, it's just the
end of this incarnation of it,
and we'll have her
and the instruments
back again in the future.
In any case, it's
just been incredibly
enriching to play this
music, to work with her,
to work with the ensemble.
So that's enough said.
This is the Lou Harrison
"Concerto for Piano
with Javanese Gamelan."
[MUSIC - LOU HARRISON, "CONCERTO
FOR PIANO WITH JAVANESE
GAMELAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]